marnie piper and cal have found love in
real life because halloween town stars
kimberly j brown and daniel koontz are
engaged
how
you cast this spell on halloweentown
while it's been over 20 years since
daniel cast a spell as cal on
halloweentown he seems to have cast a
love spell on marnie i mean kimberly the
actress shared the exciting news of
their engagement with this sweet pick of
her and daniel while flashing her ring
writing in the caption have i introduced
you guys to my fiance daniel celebrated
posting a montage of photos of them
together adorably writing in his caption
she said yes gonna love you forever
the couple also announced the news in
this tick tock featuring a timeline of
their relationship
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so let's recap that a bit
kimberly and daniel first met when they
co-starred in disney's 2001 movie
halloween town 2 calabar's revenge hey i
still need a date to the costume party
forget the party okay so they were
enemies in the film but friends in real
life and kim once revealed to fans her
often asked question were they dating at
the time that is big no yeah um because
for many reasons
but that was a long time ago
uh that was when we first met yes we met
for the movie uh but we were friends for
a very long time before we started
dating
so long after they were co-stars they
reconnected in 2016 and started filming
comedy sketches for her youtube page
together like this one
[Music]
the two sparked speculation that they
were dating at the time because of the
many cute instagram pics they shared of
each other jump to 2018 and kimberly and
daniel finally confirmed they were an
item
i would do it again
i would yeah i left feeling like oh i
could do this again yeah and since then
the couple's been giving fans a full
adorable glimpse into their love story
favorite movie this one see i picked
this question because i know the answer
to it you go ahead and
okay
what's your favorite movie i'm gonna say
back to the future
and your favorite movie i'm going to say
is drop dead gorgeous he gets that one i
think we'll we'll stay together
i think yeah i think we get each other a
little bit yeah we think so too congrats
to the happy couple
[Music]